Today in we begin a new chapter in
which is traditionally placed and
this subject matter and topic is
traditionally placed
in the chapters
of the books of regarding of
right regarding purification in the
midst of and
and so forth. And the reason for that
is that this
topic closely follows those those
topics
etc. they are all driving towards
the conditions of salah
and being that they do have a general
connection to personal hygiene
the this topic is usually placed in that
area of the books of
and that is the topic of sun
What is the singular for the word sun?
Sunnah, right? Sunnah. What is sunnah in
the Arabic language? A sunnah is a way.
A way.
And a sunn is the ways of al
meaning the
original pure disposition
upon which Allah created every human
being. The human being is naturally
created. We don't have instincts as
human beings. We don't know how to
instinctually hunt. Right? We don't know
how to instinctually fight. These are
not things that we're born with
an animal is. But we have something much
higher than that. Something that doesn't
necessarily pertain to our body, but it
pertains to our mind and our heart and
soul. And that is al the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam tells us in Bkari
Muslim.
And so the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam says every newborn
human being is born upon the fra the
natural disposition the natural
disposition
of
the oneness of Allah
only one creator the natural disposition
of understanding that
there is none worshiped along with Allah
and the natural disposition of a
general moral compass. A general moral
compass, right? Lying is wrong.
stealing is wrong. Harming or hurting,
transgressing.
a general
ingrained
compass that gives us this feeling
of right and wrong, morality, judgment,
true, false, the distinction
between just and unjust in a very
general and broad sense. This is why the
human being naturally
children and human beings when they
grow up and most human beings unless
they really really really work hard at
it have real physiological responses to
telling a lie, right? Which is how
polygraphs work. You know polygraphs
they call lie detectors. How do they
work really? Well, it just monitors
things your heart rate and your
body temperature and things that,
your blood pressure. Because when people
lie or when people fabricate falsehood,
their body physically rebels against
this. It physically responds to this.
Unless they have practiced
lying so much that they have become
pathological,
they have become a complete and utter
psychopath, then you know polygraphs
won't really do much for that kind of
person. But the human being naturally is
born with this response. And so that
general moral compass it also
entails and includes the natural
hygiene of the human being. You know how
cats naturally clean themselves, right?
That's an instinct for them. We
call that instinct. For human beings, we
have alra
which is personal hygiene. This is
how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala created
the human being with this particular
set of hygienic practices that the
person practices in himself whether it's
male or female whether it's
you know whether the person is old or
young these are the practices of alra
including the prophets and messengers
Right. So this chapter is regarding
[Silence]
Abua
narrates that the messenger of Allah.
Wasallam said five practices are of the
he says the first is
for
[Silence]
the first isad. at which is
translated almost literally to shaving.
Shaving what? Shaving the pubic hair.
Now the scholars differ on what pubic
hair really is linguistically and
legislatively.
What part of the body what what exact
hair is supposed to be removed.
The prophet sallallah.aii
first of all uses the hadith meaning
which is shaving and that is the best
way the best way with respect to the
pubic hair is to shave. What about if a
person trims it or cuts it? This is
permissible. But the best way the way
that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam did it and the companions did
it is they would use a razor or shave it
down to the skin. The pubic hair in the
correct opinion is linguistically and
legislatively
any hair which grows around the front or
back private parts of the human being.
So around the front private parts of
male or female between the legs the
area which is called the perennial which
is between the two private parts
and then any hair that is be around the
anus or between the two
you know what do you call them? glu
glutamous maximuses
whatever it is right you get the idea so
this is all called the
dead this is all called in the Arabic
language
and this is all removed all of it is all
to be shaved and as we will hear this is
all to be done at least once every 40
days at least if the grows back within
that time. Somebody has some kind of
freakishly slow regrowth of their
hair and it takes them a 100 days to
grow back then it would be once every
100 days. However, the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam for the average
person mentions 40 days in the narration
of and im Ahmed. The next he mentions is
alan. Alan is
is circumcision. Okay. Circumcision.
Circumcision traditionally is to be
done on the seventh day after boy is
born. In the correct opinion, it is
obligatory for boys. It is preferred for
girls. However, it is very different
between boys and girls and for the
boy, it is ideal to have it done on the
seventh day. However, we now live in the
super mega
you know 1984 utopia where government is
our daddy and our mommy and they do
everything for us and we can't do
anything for ourselves. used to be that
a man would have a child, take it to the
village circumciser, right? He would
circumcise it there in his thing and you
can do that at any time on the 7th day.
But now it has to be in a hospital and
they have to charge you exorbitant
amounts of money to do it. you have to
have insurance and you know you have to
make sure that you document it
because you know the government needs to
know what's between your children's
legs. So the issue now is that if you
were to take your child home and then
try to come back on the on the seventh
day to do this it will throw a monkey
branch in that in that process. So
often times circumcision is done in the
hospital before the child is taken home.
Usually one or two days one or two
days after the child is born. Is that
ideal? No. But is it correct? Yes, it's
correct. It is correct and permissible.
And it is ideally and the best time
to do the circumcision is on the seventh
day
during the
right and that's why it's called a
right however any time that it can be
done is fine.
The third is cutting or trimming the
mustache.
[Silence]
Slay.
When we look at the narrations here, we
see trimming the mustache. Now we have
different wordings of this narration in
Muslim. Some wordings tell us trimming
the the mustache meaning with scissors.
Others tell us lightening the mustache.
Others tell us shaving the mustache.
Which one of them is correct? The
correct opinion is that all of these are
acceptable. All of these are acceptable
and all of them have been narrated from
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
words.
However, they're not all on the same
level. Right? And what the three
except for the of Hanifh is that the
mustache is to be trimmed. How much
should it be trimmed? Again, this is
something that is to a person's
desire as long as it does not go down
below the top lip. This is the point
when it should be cut. There's a time
when the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
was sitting and a couple of men came and
sat down and they had very long
whiskers, mustaches.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam called for a pair of scissors
and a siwek. you know the sew and he had
each of them come and he placed the
siwak on their lip and cut what was
going beyond that. This is what he did
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when we look
at descriptions of his mustache we
see that it was cut. Is it permissible
to shave? Yes. This is the med of
and it is an acceptable med as it relies
on the narrations some of the wordings
of the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's narrations and for the most
part the all agree on this. What do they
really differ on?
What do they really differ on?
Huh?
Well, details. But even details, most of
the differences of opinion between them
and that hip is what?
What's better? What's good and what's
better? what's bad and what's worse, not
what's halal and haram. That's a very
rare difference of opinion. Where one MB
will say this is halal, another med says
this is haram. This is very rare,
extremely rare. The main difference of
opinion in mahib, we could probably say
85% even 90% of the differences in the
madib are what? in details and in better
good and better, bad and worse. The last
two and we'll these are quick. He
says
plucking the hair of the armpit. Person
may say plucking the hair of the armpit.
Yes, plucking the hair of the armpit. Is
it uncomfortable? Yes. Is there a method
to it? Yes, there is a method to doing
it. Right. We'll speak about that in a
second. But the way that the prophet did
it sallallahu alaihi wasallam is he
would pluck the hair of the armpit. He
would not shave it. And when you pluck
it, you don't have a lot of other things
that come with shaving such as
infections or ingrown hairs. And it also
takes the hair a very long time to grow
back. It's more hygienic. It is better
for the skin area. However,
shaving is acceptable and
famously said, "I personally shave mine
because I cannot handle the pain of
plucking them." This was his personal
preference.
The best way to pluck the armpit hair is
if there is sweat say at the end of a
day or a work day etc. when the hair is
a little bit that is the time when it
comes out and a person plucks it not
just grabbing and randomly pulling out
hair. You're going to be doing that all
night. it is to be done in what do
you call it an order or or you
know from top to bottom it's all the
area that is in the white skin under
the armpit and alhamdulillah once a
person begins to pluck the nerves kick
in and it goes numb in that area can
pluck it very well. This is the best
way. Is it permissible to wax it? Yeah,
it's permissible. It's going to really
hurt, right? And you know, you might
need your wife's help with that. I don't
know if that's a good look for you.
Whatever you do, you know, whatever
floats your boat, but that is all
permissible. The last and final thing
that he mentions is
which is clipping the fingernails. This
is for both men and women. Most all of
these are for for men and women except
for trimming the mustache. A woman who
has hair growing on her upper lip in
the correct opinion may
shave that or wax it or whatever to
remove it. but for a man, he is to
either shave or trim his mustache. And a
lot of that also has to do with the
place that a person lives in the
culture. here in this masid,
90% of us or 99% of us trim our
mustaches. We keep our mustaches.
There's a lot of Arabs and a lot of
old-timers that have a lot of value
for the mustache, etc. If she Ali came
in tomorrow with a completely shaved
mustache, it would be jarring, right? It
would almost be offensive. And this is
why the sunnah is so broad so that
person can do whatever will make them
fit in the most.
And so trimming the fingernails again
the absolute longest a person may go
without trimming his fingernails is 40
days as the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam mentioned. However trimming of
the fingernails should take place
anytime the fingernails become a harbor
of dirt and become unhygienic. When
the fingernail grows to the point where
it starts holding grease, holding dirt,
holding person uses the bathroom etc.
can't clean himself properly. This is
when it becomes necessary to trim the
fingernails if not at least once every
40 days. And that goes for women as
well. what would our prophet's
reaction be to seeing our women that say
taking
plastic fingernails that look claws
off of something that crawled out of
hell and putting plastering them onto
their hands to where it's you
know, this is
there's no class. It's not even classy,
right? But further than that, it is
categorically haram for a number of
reasons. And we'll discuss this in more
detail next time.